we finished novel I was a I drink coffee
maybe a few times a week tops
I definitely don't drink it daily I kind
of lean towards a sweet side and get
like four to six packs of sugar don't
touch me okay I would rather not have
coffee at all than to have it with milk
or black it needs to be with cream I
wish I could be one of those cool people
who like only drinks black coffee
I really don't drink coffee that often
but I'm easing into it like a badass and
I only drink it black if I'm just like
in a bad mood I'll just drink it black
and make myself more miserable I mean
that's the best thing about coffee you
can cater it to your tastes
I can be with ice company thank you you
know it's pretty normal innocent enough
it smells really good
sounds like a sweet coffee yeah let's
give her a whirl go for it oh mama
that's really sweet I like that it's
good though it is like a little bit
thick ooh
shake with us ladies that is probably
the proper thing I would hydrate with
this really I could like come into the
office and grab one of these bad boys
every morning done and done it's like a
wah wah iced coffee anything with
condensed milk is amazing I'm with it
a plus kudos to the Vietnamese
interesting color going on here this
looks like iced tea watch it be iced tea
it's gonna be icing that's gonna be
coffee whoa
that has like some sour undertones going
on it tastes like I see it does taste
like ice tea
Oh see is there coffee in this I don't
hate it I would drink this at brunch
yeah
[Music]
artisinal oh this is Greek coffee you're
like it's gonna be deserted
do I need to stir it I think you should
it smells strong
like there's a lotta thean in this see
this tastes like ooh I feel like I'm
gonna grow a moustache drinking this is
it so heavy tastes like a firework
tastes like smoked coffee when you like
let off a firework and like the smoke
and all that like gets in their face
it's gorgeous and presentation at first
glance I'd be like oh this is probably
gonna taste good but nope I'm gonna pass
on this one
me too I'm not gonna lie you kind of
like has grown on me a little bit
[Music]
I like the this way of it not a super
strong smell
I like this normal color of my coffee I
would say smells like it's gonna be
really good all right let's see that oh
my god this thing's amazing it has an
aftertaste of green tea it's a little
more watered-down then I thought it
would be not like a super strong flavor
but it tastes pretty good I think I
would rather just drink tea or coffee I
don't want to need them together
it tastes like green tea tea so
misleading I pass Austrians
what are you doing that you're putting
raw egg in your coffee mm-hmm
that smells very strongly like things is
it cuz we know there are eggs and that's
what I was gonna say I mean the color
looks nice it looks like any other
normal coffee I don't trust it I'm so
nervous cuz I already know what's in it
you go first
to raw eggs I'm gonna go for it oh you
just took oh he took a big-ass sip
that's good oh my god that's really good
what you don't look too close to the
chunks of egg it tastes pretty damn good
did you just draw my attention to the
jumping eggs look I think I will keep
drinking cuz this is amazing it's
definitely morning coffee okay a little
breakfast gonna - I think the egg thing
does kind of go to your head a little
bit but I don't think I have a big
problem with it I said a coconut just
throw in your coffee
this one is sweetened condensed milk
coffee black tea there's tea in it
that's the tea that's the notes oh my
god this is combining coffee and tea
[Music]